you do believe that aliens do exist yeah
that's a check
these people claim that they've been
kidnapped by aliens and they've been
in the flying saucers steal an alien
chip pencil
paperweight there's no law against
stealing from an extraterrestrial
civilization
that'll end the debate right then and
there time travel
we realize that if you have a wormhole
there is a theory that you can go
backwards in time
the big bang is what happens when
universes collide
we live in an ocean of parallel
universes the next question you're going
to ask is elvis presley still alive in a
parallel universe
probably yes belting out hit after hit
according to
the quantum theory you think we're going
to get to a point where
with advanced medicine and technology we
can
live forever i think that our grandkids
will hit the age of 30
and stop the buildup of genetic and
cellular mistakes
that's what aging is with gene therapy
perhaps we can reverse that aging
process
what separates us from the animals teach
your dog the meaning of tomorrow
it's impossible animals live in the
present their prefrontal cortex is not
fully developed they don't
imagine the future and that's what
separates humans
from animals
[Music]
so my guest today is a theoretical
physicist and on top of that if you go
online he's probably got i don't know
maybe a billion views of him sharing his
ideas he's got one of those minds that
you can't
you'll sit there you'll say i can watch
10 minutes of his content
next thing you know you're watching him
for a couple hours a beautiful mind he's
got he just came out with a recent book
called the god equation that came out on
april 6 and it's already a new york
times bestseller and an amazon
bestseller this is his fifth bestseller
with that being said my guest today dr
michio kaku
doc thanks for being a guest on
valuetainment my pleasure
great honor yeah so so so tell us the
idea
behind writing the book god equation
well it all started when i was eight
years old
a great scientist had just died and all
the papers published a picture
of his desk just this desk and on the
desk was an unfinished open
book and the caption caught my attention
it said the greatest scientist of our
time could not
finish this book well
i was i was shocked what
it's a homework problem why couldn't he
ask his mother
what could be so hard that a great
scientist couldn't finish it
so i went to the library and i found out
this man's name was
albert einstein and that book
was to be the god equation an equation
perhaps no more than one
inch long that would allow us to quote
read the mind
of god so i said to myself wow that's
for me that's what i want to do when i
grow up
so when i was in high school i wanted to
be part of this great revolution
so i wanted to build an atom smasher a
particle accelerator in my mom's garage
i said to my mom can i have can i have
permission to build a 2.3
million electron-involved betatron
accelerator in the garage
and my mom said sure why not
don't forget to take out the garbage
well i took out the garbage i assembled
400 pounds of transformer steel
six kilowatts of power and i built a
better joint accelerator in the garage
at the time how old were you when he did
that i was 17 years old
holy moly and every time i plugged it in
i would
blow out all the circuit breakers
my poor mom she'd come home all the
lights would flicker and die
and she must have said why couldn't i
have a son who plays
baseball why can't he find why can't he
play basketball
and for god's sake why can't he find a
nice japanese girlfriend
why does he have to build these machines
in the garage
now you grew up in san jose right this
is san jose when this is happening
well i was born in san jose and i grew
up in palo alto
okay got it and i went to the national
science fair where i earned the
attention
of a nuclear scientist edward teller who
actually
built the first hydrogen bomb
and so he arranged for me to get a
scholarship to harvard so when i
graduated from harvard
he offered me a job it was a job
designing hydrogen bombs
so i said to myself hmm do i want to
spend the rest of my life designing
hydrogen warheads
so i respectfully declined his very kind
very generous offer
because i wanted to work on an even
bigger
explosion i wanted to work on the big
bang the creation of the universe
because that's what the god equation is
all about the god equation
set the universe into motion
and we are all byproducts so that one
equation that
mesmerized my intention when i was eight
years old
that's that's amazing so eight years old
is when einstein died by the way i
i own one uh statue that's about 150
pounds and i
take it with me everywhere i go every
office i've been from california when we
move to dallas to moving here
i keep it with me it's einstein statute
it's him smoking a
pipe and it's a statue that was put
together by uh
i think his name is bill mack i don't
know if you know bill mackey does some
real good work
and uh i'm a big fan of einstein as well
but what i'm curious about with you is
if i was in high school with you
obviously i know you finished first in
harvard in your physics class and
you know you were the number one
graduating i mean you you've been at the
top everywhere but
if i was 14 15 16 years old with you
i'm sitting right next to you and i'm
friends with you
who was uh who was michio kaku at 16
years old
well i had two role models when i was
16.
first of course was to try to follow in
albert einstein's footsteps
but second i used to watch the old flash
gordon series on television saturday
morning
and i was hooked i mean starships aliens
from other planets
ray guns invisibility shields and then
later in life i began to realize hey
these two loves of my life science
fiction and theoretical physics
are really the same thing because if you
understand deeply the laws of physics
then you know what is possible what is
plausible
and what is simply ridiculous and
impossible
and so having a good foundation in
physics made all the difference in the
world
you know all of biology can be explained
in the language of chemistry
all of chemistry can be explained in the
language of
physics but all of physics can be
explained in the language of
relativity like the big bang and the
quantum theory which gives us
transistors
and lasers and the internet but these
two
these two hands of god don't communicate
with each other
they hate each other and that's the goal
the goal is to merge
these two great theories to create an
equation
one inch long maybe that would allow us
to unravel
the universe itself that's the holy
grail
the holy grail of science sounds like
today's politics we can't get the guys
on both sides to talk to each other
these two guys hate each other so so but
but were you the
were you the quiet guy were you the guy
that uh you know always had the right
answers were you always talking about
hey you know what do you think is out in
space
which one were you i'm actually really
curious well i did a lot of reading
about aliens and outer space and the
fourth dimension and parallel universes
and black holes
but you know it was so frustrating
because when i went to the library and i
looked up
hyperspace parallel universes higher
dimensions
i found nothing there was nothing in the
library
and i said to myself when i grow up and
i become a theoretical physicist
i'm going to write books for myself as a
child
i'm going to do research and try to
complete einstein's dream but on the
side is a hobby
right for myself as a child wondering
what is possible all these things on
science fiction all these things you see
in the movies
warp drive and antimatter are they real
or is it just some hollywood script
writer's imagination
so i said to myself i'm going to write
kids i'm going to write books
for children my age who were wondering
what's it all about got it that makes so
you knew early on you were going to be a
theoretical physicist you didn't
right that's so good right at what age
did you know that what it was like this
is what i'm going to do the rest of my
life
well by about sixth grade that's what i
knew
this this is it and you know we are all
born scientists
when we're born we want to know why the
sun shines we want to know where we come
from
but then then we hit the greatest
destroyer of scientists
known to science the greatest destroyer
of scientists is
junior high school because in
junior high school that's when
scientists made boring
memorization list of names and facts and
figures you're never going to use anyway
that are totally irrelevant because you
know science is based on
principles concepts physical
pictures that's what drives science like
evolution like relativity like newton's
laws
not memorizing einstein's middle name
that's not
science at all and so that's why we lose
so many people in the danger years 15
16 17. those are the danger years when
we lose
millions of young kids that's powerful
everyone's a scientist
sixth grade until junior high school
then the educational system kind of
messes you up it's more memorization
than
creating testing things see what happens
so so that took me to two different
directions one of the things i want to
talk about is the educational system
i'll get to that later on but
right now since we're talking about your
book what
were you raised in a certain
denomination
as like what was the meaning of god to
you when your parents spoke to you about
it
well my parents were buddhists and in
buddhism
there is no beginning or end there's
just timeless
nirvana but they put me in a
presbyterian sunday school
so i grew up as a presbyterian learning
about
god and genesis and the books of the
bible
and then i had two a contradictory
ideas in my head either the universe had
a beginning
or it didn't no two ways around it until
now now we realize that our universe is
a bubble of some sort it's expanding
and that's called the big bang theory we
live on the skin of this expanding
bubble
but string theory which is what i'm one
of the pioneers in this theory called
string theory
string theory says that there are other
bubbles out there
other bubbles floating in nirvana
so in other words our universe had a
beginning like
genesis our universe had a beginning but
there are other universes in a bubble
bath
a bubble bath of universes and when
these universes collide
or fission that's the big bang
so the big bang is what happens when
universes collide
and these universes expand in what
nirvana that's what these bubbles expand
into timeless nirvana and so we live
in an ocean of parallel universes and
then
the next question you're going to ask me
i'm sure is
is elvis presley still alive in a
parallel universe
of course and the answer is probably yes
that he's probably alive in some
parallel universe belting out hit
after hit according to the quantum
theory
i can't believe missing out on all those
hits you know it's way too many he's
probably on the same place with him
tupac and the rest of them that are
making hits uh for the rest of us so
so so you're uh raised the buddhist
and there is no beginning there's no end
it's just kind of like a flow
and then you go to presbyterian school
genesis you learn all this stuff there
is a beginning
and then later on big bang theory the
the clashes of
you know different uh uh different ideas
that come together
and then you have nirvana okay fine
today
you've been around for a long time
meaning you've been debating a lot of
different people you've seen a lot of
different ideas you see a lot of
different
theories what is your interpretation
when you hear
a pastor or preacher of their religion
get up and sell their faith with the
kind of conviction that they have
how do you process that well i like to
call
galileo who once said that the purpose
of science
is to determine how the heavens go
but the purpose of religion is to
determine how to go
to heaven so in other words science is
about natural law
how the heavens go how the planets move
how the galaxy moves
but religion is about how to go to
heaven
that is ethics how to be a good person
how to obey the laws and help your
neighbors and so as long as we keep
these
two separate they are complementary
the problem occurs however when people
who are in the natural sciences
pontificate about ethics
or when religious people pontificate
about natural law
that's where we get into trouble but as
long as we keep these two things
relatively separate they
are complementary so i don't see any
contradiction between the two
very cool that's interesting to take
that angle so so in your
eyes you have i think you have two kids
right
you have two kids so in your eyes what
do you think happens when we die
well the short answer is i don't know
but you know in my books
and in my interviews with other
scientists i begin to realize that
science is closing
in on mortality genetic immortality
is a possibility and also digital
immortality is a possibility
for example uh everything known about us
can be digitized
our credit card transactions our emails
to give an approximation of
well who we are our digital soul
i would love for example to talk to
einstein
one day somebody will digitize him
everything known about his writings his
interviews his inner thoughts
his letters one day we
will be digitized meaning that our
digital footprint
will be digitized and live forever on
the internet so that we can talk
to our great great great great great
grandkids and our great great great
great grandkids can talk
to us because we've been digitized and
that's coming
faster than you realize silicon valley
is already
offering the capability of digitizing
what is known about you now
imagine what's going to happen in the
years in the future
will have a very good approximation of
who you are
and in that sense we will live forever
got it
so what a and by the way i fully see i
can only imagine you go to a
vault and you're sitting in this vault
and you have access to
great minds to you know i want to
interview with einstein have a
conversation with them i want to
interview with you know
some evil people in history to say what
motivated you one can like imagine you
have a conversation with hitler why'd
you do what you do what was the
motivation behind it why are you
uh um that would tell us a lot and that
would be very interesting to go in that
angle but do you think
the opposite side so digital immortality
i fully see that i think it's already
happened in any ways people are creating
content
where even the element of documentation
when i'm
vlogging that's a form of digital
immortality because my
great great great grandkids can sit
there and watch me for hours and say wow
that's my great great great grandfather
i can't exactly do you think the element
of
like immortality itself of the flesh
and the spirit do you think you think
we're gonna get to a point where
with advanced medicine and technology
we can live forever you think that's a
possibility
well look at it this way why do we die
we die because of the buildup of error
error in our dna errors in our cells
because of chaos the second law of
thermodynamics things rust things fall
apart
things die but if you add energy from
the outside
you can get around the second law of
thermodynamics for example with gene
therapy
we'll be able to attack aging at three
levels
one is telomerase we know that a cell
has a clock
a clock skin cells divide 60 times and
then they go with the senescence and
then
they die why the telomeres get shorter
and shorter and shorter it's like a
clock
after 60 reproductions the cell dies
however we've now discovered telomerase
a nobel prize was given for the
discovery of telomerase it stops the
clock
now why don't we all take telomerase got
to be careful
this is powerful stuff you see
telomerase also
is used by cancer cells cancer cells are
also immortal
that's why they kill you because they
are immortal
and that's one way that cancer cells
become immortal
so we have to control telomerase second
we know that if you live want to live 30
longer eat 30 percent less
this has been checked on spiders insects
uh mammals all the way up to
primates you feed them 30 percent less
they live 30 percent longer why is that
well we're not sure because you slow
down the oxidation process
and mother nature knows that in case of
a famine
animals face famine all the time animals
have a choice
they can either reproduce or they can
gut it out
and go to senescence hibernate whatever
and then when there's food flourish once
again
so we now have isolated the genes that
control
this process of gutting it out
during times of famine which of course
is very common for
animals and uh many people are looking
at these enzymes
which slow down metabolism because we
want to live forever without having to
live like a monk
we don't want to eat 30 less we want to
eat lots of food
and still live longer and that gets us
into oxidation
why do cars get old what ages in a car
well it's the engine why the engine
because that's where you have combustion
oxidation wear and tear
well where is the engine of a cell
the mitochondria bingo we now know where
errors
build up in a cell the mitochondria and
with gene therapy with crispr technology
one day
i think that our maybe our grandkids
will hit the age of 30
and stop they may like being 30 for many
decades to come
i think that's well within the realm of
possibility
given the rapidity with which we are now
unraveling the question
why do we have to die
listen why couldn't you have been my
teacher when i went to high school like
seriously
if i had you as a science teacher i
would have gone to school twice
i would have gone to school on sundays
if i had you as a school teacher the way
you're teaching is just something else
uh so so let's let's go there there's
couple things you said there so
living forever so do you think it is a
good idea for us to live forever do you
think it's a good idea that we have a
you know we eventually die and we're
replaced and replenished by somebody
newer that comes with better ideas
you know more creative ideas what do you
think about the idea of actually
being beneficial to the world for us to
eventually die
well there is a benefit to dying and
that is
on a societal level you don't want to
stagnate
you don't want ideas that are old
crusted
and obsolete to dominate young people
who may
think differently so on one hand you
want to you want to transport the wisdom
you want to get the wisdom of a
generation and give the next generation
that
wisdom of life because life is more
complicated than any simple formula
however sometimes people begin to get
uh you know old and tired
and they want the young generation to be
just as old and tired as they
are and that's not a good idea that will
cause
stagnation that's why i say that in the
future
when people live forever or live very
long when they hit the age of 30
that's a good age to stop because you're
still
young enough to have vibrant ideas but
you still have
the wisdom the wisdom of the first 30
years of your life
so i think if and when we have the
ability to stop
aging that is stop the second law of
thermodynamics
then 30 is a good age to live forever
i get what you're saying so if i can get
to a certain age and just stop and be 30
for the next 200 years that's kind of
cool to stay 30 for 200 more years
that's right you can still look at new
kinds of music and new kinds of crazy
bizarre ideas
with the wisdom of the past that makes
sense
but you're still open to it you're like
okay this is cool i can get you so i can
still adjust to
new direction oh now we're using the
internet i can adjust to no now we're
using netflix i can adjust to the
lifestyles also changes
versus no this is how it's been for a
long time and i'm not willing to
pivot nor adjust to it question for you
about movies so a lot of movies we watch
over the years uh and the first time we
watch it we're like there's no way in
the world that's gonna happen it's just
not going to happen that's impossible
that's pretty cool to sit there and
think about the idea
that's kind of cool you know that's
that's pretty intense to see something
like that
you know and then you know for example i
don't know if you've seen the movie
benjamin button
if you've seen the movie benjamin button
he is aging backwards which is pretty
crazy
right or even the movie age of adeline i
don't know if you've seen the movie age
of adults
i've seen age of adeline i go to one
scene in age of adeline
and i've probably seen that scene i'm
not even kidding with you it's my wife
thinks i'm crazy
probably two or three hundred times it's
the scene where adeline walks in
and she's dating her his son and she
turns around and looks at him it's like
adeline
and then she doesn't know how to answer
and this to mom you know which scene i'm
talking about it's in the house when
that
is scene takes place but she gets struck
by lightning
due to a car crash and she can't age and
the way she
started aging again is when she got
struck in lightning because of the
second car accident she started aging
because you got a gray hair
so she was celebrating getting a gray
hair because that means immortality is
not an
effect for her or even back to the
future where we can go on a time machine
right
how many of these movies that come up
with these ideas or
accidental ideas because somebody was
smoking the right you know pot or
they were on lsd or they were being
delusional and let me write about this
this be kind of cool
and how much of this is a visionary
envisioning a future that maybe the rest
of the world hasn't yet envisioned and
it's just an imagination
is it accidental or is it something
that's actually uh something someone
believes that's gonna happen
well when i saw that movie with adeline
i was very curious about exactly how
a lightning bolt would make her immortal
and the narrator actually lays out a
scenario
i followed i followed the gobble the
i followed the reasoning
and they said that the lightning bolt
changed her biochemistry
and the genes the genes that control the
aging process
were altered by the lightning bolt and
it lays out a scenario
where biochemistry biochemistry is at
the root
of immortality now look at it this way
why do we have to die look at the
greenland shark
the greenland shark lives to be about
500 years of
age we know that because just like tree
rings
you can look at the eyeball of the fish
count the rings
and calculate the age of these fish
and they are between 400 to 500 years of
age
so in other words why do we have to die
in the arctic where these fish are
metabolism is much slower and slower
metabolism means
air is built up slower and again that's
what aging is
the buildup of genetic and cellular
mistakes
they build up cells get sluggish they
eventually
die as a consequence but with gene
therapy
perhaps we can reverse that aging
process
correct the mistakes and that's where
the adeline
movie comes in a lightning bolt did it
in the movie
maybe we can do it using biochemistry in
the laboratory so this is something that
we should think about
it's not for us we're not there yet but
we have tantalizing clues as to the
mechanism
of how aging takes place in cells
in worms for example we can actually
double their lifespan
and as i mentioned you can take any
animal up to
humans and make them live 30 percent
longer
now this has not been tested in humans
by the way it's been tested in dogs
cats primates you eat 30 percent less
you live 30
longer why hasn't it been tested in
humans
well let's be blunt humans bellyache too
much
if they don't like something they sue
you and who wants to be sued
so in other words it'll be a while
before we test
humans by having them eat 30 percent
less
so that that's age of adeline you're
right the humans sue humans i have not
seen too many dogs suing dogs and that
that's
i think that's a scientific statement
right there but
so benjamin button fake can that happen
can somebody age backwards you know
and then back to the future what why are
we waiting so long to come up with this
time machine why can't we have it
already
well aging backwards would violate the
second law of thermodynamics
the second law of thermodynamics says
that in a closed system
things decay things get older things
fall apart things die
the key word is closed in a closed
system things naturally get older in an
open system like you have
sunlight energy from the sun that can
reverse the process
that's how evolution takes place
evolution should
violate the second law of thermodynamics
people get
uh i mean if you take a look at human
evolution we got
smarter we got more adapted to the
environment
why because we had extra energy from the
outside
sunlight now that open system could be
biochemistry
and so biochemistry could replace
sunlight and speed up this process
instead of waiting millions of years for
evolution to catch up
we may be able to do it in one
generation now time travel
that's something that we physicists
actually look into
and we realize that if you have a
wormhole there is a theory that you can
go backwards in time
now in 1935 it was einstein himself who
postulated the existence of wormholes
that i mentioned in my book
the god equation if i have two universes
parallel to each other
and i create a bridge a bridge between
these two universes
then you fall into one and go into the
other now the energy to do this
is the energy of a black hole so in
other words if there's a white hole
a white hole on the other end of a black
hole
it means that you can fall in and fall
out someplace
else in the universe now this of course
raises paradoxes
what happens if you go backwards in time
and commit suicide
that is you kill yourself as a young
child
then how can you live if you just killed
yourself as a young child
well there's a way around it and in
quantum mechanics there's something
called the many worlds theory
that every time a measurement is made
the universe
splits in half and keeps on splitting
every time there's a
an observation being made and so maybe
when you go backwards in time
the river of time forks
into two rivers so
if you go to backwards in time to save
abraham lincoln from being assassinated
at the fourth theater
you've saved somebody else's abraham
lincoln
your abraham lincoln and your river of
time
died with an assassin's bullet that
cannot be changed
but the river of time splits
and forks and you've saved another
universe's abraham lincoln from being
assassinated
that is what we physicists think is a
possible resolution
of all time travel paradoxes the river
of time
forks that's some deep stuff i feel like
i'm high right now just listening to you
but by the way what are your thoughts on
drugs and and uh you know lsd and and
you know taking certain drugs scientists
to
see the world from a different element
you know you hear the stories about
steve jobs
was tested with lsd a little bit just to
kind of get his brain a little bit more
creative
what are your thoughts about certain
drugs helping see the world from a
different lens that others don't see
well one downside is addiction
and addiction will eventually kill you
because you get addicted to
a drug that interferes with the
biochemistry of the body
drugs that are mild like marijuana we
can go back and forth back and forth
looking at the data
but hard drugs will mess up the brain
and create an alternate reality so
people who are creative
artists and writers and people who make
their living
being imaginative i can see why they
would want to do it
but the pitfall is it could control
you to the point that you get addicted
and you're a slave
you become a slave to this drug creating
the drug
industry which is a multi-billion dollar
industry which paralyzes whole
governments
hold governments in latin america are
paralyzed because of the drug cartel
which makes money on people getting high
and so i think that there's a downside
to this as well
yeah that's that's a very uh have you
ever have you ever been curious about
testing your own brain
like have you yourself gone and wanted
to do mris and
to study the difference between i had uh
who's the guest i had on who was a brain
uh
uh daniel dr daniel uh uh
amen dr daniel amen i brought him on and
he said
he has done i don't know how many mris
on the brain you know 175 000 some major
number that he gave and he's looked at
so many different things
do you think there is a way to look at
someone's brain to say this person's
brain vibrates at a different level
with ideas the coloring all that other
stuff have you investigated that at all
or no
well i've had my brain scanned several
times
i've hosted a few documentaries for bbc
television
and they flew me down to north carolina
where
they have one of the the finest mri
machines
and you can actually see thoughts as
they emerge in the brain
you can actually see centers of the
brain light up like a christmas tree
and so many of the secrets of the brain
are being revealed
for example the back of the brain is the
so-called reptilian brain
it's the brain of hunger balance
aggression
the brain that a snake would have in the
back of the brain or an alligator
the center of the brain is more or less
the monkey brain
the limbic brain the brain of social
structures that is the brain of how to
defer to your elders
how to be kind to people the the brain
that involves
pac mentality that's the center of the
brain
and then the question is what are we
what separates us from the animals
what separates us from the animals is
the front of the brain
the prefrontal cortex and so what does
it do
what separates us from the animals the
front of the brain
is a time machine it daydreams
it constantly conjures up images of
imagined futures for example let's do an
experiment
go home tonight and talk to your dog and
teach your dog the meaning of tomorrow
very simple teach your dog the meaning
of tomorrow
you can't it's impossible because
animals live in the present their
prefrontal cortex
is not fully developed they don't
imagine the future
and that's what separates humans from
animals we live in the future
brain scans constantly show that when
somebody is daydreaming about the future
they're actually accessing the past past
memories and then altering it
to create alternate futures that's how
we recall images
if you brain scan an animal you find out
that they don't
think about the past they don't think
about the future
they only think about the present
so that's what separates humans from
animals
humans live in the future here we
constantly daydream
plot scheme we're constantly thinking
what can i do
what does that mean why is he saying
this we're constantly thinking about
gossip
about alternate futures what if i did
what if i
what if i did this what if i did that
that's called
humanity that's why we differ from the
animals
because if you read the mind of an
animal all they're worried about is
where's lunch where's dinner that's
pretty much
it when you brain scan an animal no
wonder they're so happy
well maybe chihuahuas are pissed off
because maybe chihuahuas do see the
future i don't know i mean there's uh
certain dogs that have a pretty terrible
temper they're not happy about anything
but yeah i can't see that that makes a
lot of sense
uh look you know we've covered a lot of
things here let's go kind of to
the next part here we can talk about
aliens and extraterrestrial
you know terrestrial um you saw a lot of
things have been coming up lately
well you know the we found that there
was
you know connection and contact with
another uh uh
i think it was about a year and a half
ago or a year ago where we saw a video
where the
pilot is talking about wait a minute
what is this all about and then
something came about
a week ago or maybe even two weeks ago i
think we're at a point where
people are not disputing that there is a
life
out there uh uh in the uh you know
outer space there is life out there in
the outer space but i guess the question
i would have for you would be the
following
area 51 used to be a myth and it's no
longer a myth
it's you know it's people kind of know
about it they're going out there you
know sitting outside and kind of making
videos
do you think because we don't know much
about aliens
we believe they exist we've seen
images we've seen images in movies
we've been told they exist and we're at
a point that we believe it
do you think aliens know about our
existence and are
they watching us or are they just as
oblivious as we are
about them as they are about us well i
get a lot of emails and some of them say
professor you're wrong you're totally
wrong
the aliens are not there the aliens are
here they're among us and how do they
know these people claim that they've
been kidnapped
they've been kidnapped by aliens and
they've been in the flying saucers
so i have a word of advice the next time
you are kidnapped by a flying saucer for
god's sake
steal something steal an alien chip
an alien pencil an alien paperweight
steal
something because there's no law against
stealing from an extraterrestrial
civilization
you're not going to go to jail where's
the law that says you can't steal from
an alien civilization
and then you'll have bragging rights
that'll end the debate
right then and there period end of story
end of debate
you have an alien chip that proves that
you've been in that flying saucer
now when you're walking down a forest
and you meet a squirrel
do you go down to the squirrels and talk
to it well maybe initially hey hi
squirrel but eventually you get bored
because
the squirrel has nothing to say to you i
mean it's
boring talking to a squirrel they have
nothing to add
no insights no funny stories nothing
they just run away for the next acorn so
if we are the squirrels
and aliens from outer space land on the
earth what do we have to offer them
shakespeare well maybe they don't
understand english
what do we have to offer them gold gold
means nothing to them
in fact gold is rather a useless medal
for an advanced civilization
what do they want to eat us
we're not going to be made out of the
same dna they're not going to
want to eat us or mate with us or do
anything with our genome
we're totally different from them so i
think for the most part
they'll leave us alone they'll say oh
nice squirrel
and leave us alone so in other words
in other words you're saying that
if they did know about us they would
leave us alone are you saying
so first of all let me just kind of set
the tone here with this part you do
believe that
aliens do exist that's a check right
yeah that's a check yeah okay so that's
a check okay so
do you believe because you've also said
in the past that it's probably not a
good idea to wake them up just like
cortez you know was going against you
know
you don't want to let the enemy know
that you
[Music]
are out there it's better for you to
stay quiet and not make a lot of noise
and not let them know about you
are you saying that because you don't
believe they know of our existence yet
well put it this way
there's a group called the meti project
which deliberately
deliberately sends signals into outer
space saying
here we are here's what we like this is
what we can do
and visit us sometime i think that's a
bad idea
because we don't know what their
intentions are
maybe they've been scanning us maybe
they know pretty much
where what our technological development
level is
they know a lot about us our language
our culture they're
pretty advanced but for the most part
we're not interesting to them
but one day if we advertise our
existence and reveal how much we have
resources minerals perhaps things that
are of value to an alien civilization
then just like was mentioned cortes
well montezuma thought that cortez was a
god
big mistake one of the biggest mistakes
in history
cortez was a pirate he was a
bloodthirsty
pirate but what did he have he had steel
while the aztecs had bronze he had the
horse the aztecs had
no horse cortez had the written language
the aztecs had no written language
and cortez had smallpox and that of
course
devastated the population so i think for
the most part it's a bad idea
to advertise our existence to aliens in
outer space
in other words maybe we're off the radar
let's keep it that way for a while
do you believe we are off the right do
you do you believe we're off their radar
right now
well i think aliens probably have more
important things to worry about because
if you
are a a person walking in a forest there
are lots of forest animals out there
some forest animals are probably more
interesting than squirrels
and so i think there's a lot more
interesting things for them to be
preoccupied with
so i think for the most part we should
lie low
but i think they're out there you know
we've analyzed 4 000 planets so far
4 000 of which roughly 20 percent
seem to be earth-like now that expanding
to the galaxy
means that there are billions billions
of earth-like planets maybe a little bit
bigger than the earth
but billions of earth-like planets out
there to assume that we're the only one
i think is the height of arrogance
i i agree it's naive or arrogant by the
way when you said the quartz at smallpox
did you mean
he used the smallpox you kill his enemy
well
the conquistadors we don't know which
conquistador brought smallpox
but we know the conquistadors brought
diseases
to the new world and the the aztecs had
no
no immune system no defense against
these so it wasn't cortez personally
it was the conquistadors that brought
smallpox to the new world
as a use of a weapon or accidental they
had it and they just brought it in it
spread
probably accidental okay got it makes
sense so it wasn't like an intentional
thing that they did okay
so so do you think there's a twin up
earth out there in the world that maybe
two thousand years ahead of us or five
thousand years ahead of us or a thousand
years behind us do you think there's a
there could be a possibility of twin of
an earth
i think there are probably doppelgangers
out there
that are just like the planet earth and
they could be millions of years ahead of
us
now many of my friends you know they're
all physicists when you talk aliens to
them their eyes kind of like roll up
into the heavens and they start to shake
their heads
that's the giggle factor that whenever
you talk to them about that
and why do they giggle they say the
distance between stars is so great it
would take
hundreds thousands of years for them to
reach us but you see
that assumes they are a hundred years
ahead of us
and of course a hundred years ahead of
us a civilization like that cannot reach
the earth
but for the moment think of what could
happen if they are
a million years ahead of us if they were
a million years ahead of us
and our science is only 300 years old
300 years ago we lived in witchcraft
sorcery magic that's where we were 300
years ago
if there are millionaires ahead of us
which is a blink of an eye
a blink of an eye because the universe
is 13.8
billion years old then think
that their understanding of the laws of
physics
would be completely different from our
understanding of the laws of physics
you see our understanding of the laws of
physics breakdown
breakdown at the instant of creation the
big bang
and the center of a black hole we don't
know anything about the center of a
black hole
or the instant of creation new laws of
physics
open up perhaps wormholes gateways
that allow us to go faster than the
speed of light
and so get rid of all your prejudices
that they can't reach us
because they're only 100 years ahead of
us if there are millionaires ahead of us
new laws of physics begin to open up
i'm i'm trying to wrap my head around if
there's a double ganger say it's a twin
of ours and they're
million years years ahead of us and they
have feelings emotions
opinions they're thinking about the
future and the past
there's probably going to be opposing
beliefs religions technology
advancements power the
the temptation of wanting to rule the
world and all that other stuff
i i i don't i don't know about that
because and
here here's kind of what again i may be
wrong i'm not a theoretical physicist
but uh do you think the way we're going
right now
we can exist a thousand years from now
two thousand years from now four
thousand years from the reason why i'm
asking this question is
one is from the advancement standpoint
okay on how much we're advancing
right it seems like right now we're
the level of acceleration of advancement
is about to go
in a different gear we're about to
downshift second gear and it's gonna
go and i think the separation's gonna be
further than ever before uh some are
just gonna get way hit i mean you're
starting to see the the level of wealth
that's being made you got
musk at what couple hundred billion
right now one day he's 140 one day he's
160 got bezos
a couple hundred and then you have
technology things that nft people still
don't even know what an nfd is people
still don't even know what a bitcoin is
people are still trying to learn
what the hell is going on and at the
same time we are wanting to be important
and i'm important look at me i'm smart
i'm wealthy i'm powerful
i'm a politician do you think we can be
around a thousand years from now without
somebody finally saying screw all of you
i'm gonna pull the plug
boom it's over with well we physicists
have
actually tried to describe civilization
thousands millions of years ahead of us
and we categorize them by energy
a type one civilization is a
civilization that controls planetary
power
they control the weather earthquakes
volcanoes they can modify them
anything earthbound they have the energy
to control
that's type one type two civilization
controls the energy of the sun
directly they harness the solar flares
they energize the entire solar system
because they control
the sun that's type two type three
is galactic they roam the galactic space
lanes
they've colonized the entire galaxy
black holes
stars supernovas they roam the entire
galaxy
now on this scale of energy what are we
are we type one that control the weather
volcanoes earthquakes
are we type two that control solar
flares and the energy of the entire sun
are we type three that roam the galactic
space lanes
no we're type zero we get our energy
from oil and coal
that's dead plants we're type zero
but we are about a hundred years from
becoming type one
that's what all the headlines are about
what is the internet
the internet is the first type one
technology to fall
into this century it is a planetary
technology
the internet what about the language of
type one
well on the internet already english and
mandarin chinese are the two most
popular languages
on the internet what about culture we're
seeing the beginning of planetary sports
with the olympics and with soccer we see
the beginning of a planetary
music youth culture youth music rap
music rock and roll
we're seeing the beginning of a type 1
culture in fashion
gucci chanel so we're beginning to see
the beginning
of a type 1 civilization right in front
of us
but that's the danger the most dangerous
transition is between type zero to type
one
why because if we're type zero we have
all the savagery
all the brutality of our past we came
from the swamp
just 300 years ago 300 years ago there
was only magic
superstition inquisitions torture
that's the way it was just 300 years ago
and now we're headed toward
type one every time we open the
newspaper i see the beginning
of the birth of a type 1 civilization a
planetary civilization
look at the pandemic it's a planetary
pandemic but how do we deal with it
globally globally we did it and we're
conquering it
now that was impossible just a hundred
years ago during the 1918
spanish flu outbreak now we can actually
control outbreaks like this
so we're seeing the birth of a type 1
civilization but it's dangerous
because we now have nuclear weapons we
have the ability to create designer
germs
we have the ability to alter the weather
with global warming
so it's not clear whether we're going to
make the transition from type 0 to type
but this is the greatest transition in
human history
we are privileged to be alive to see
this transition from type zero
to type one so so from from your
research from
i don't if you've done or if you haven't
done what was
uh uh hitler's reasoning for having the
level of hate that he had
from your research from what you read
why why did he have that kind of hate
for
a different or you know jews or whatever
you know
the level of hate he had for them well
you see before we become
type one we have all the savagery of
type
zero we came from the swamp think about
it
think of what life was like just a few
hundred years ago
a life expectancy for example something
as simple as that
was 30 years of age for most of human
history
we lived in a savage barbaric past
just struggling to stay alive and of
course
having enemies was a very convenient way
to keep the masses
happy and contented look at the roman
empire many attempts were made to try to
create
a civilization but they all failed
why did they fail because there was not
enough wealth to go around
poverty sickness disease but now we have
the industrial revolution
the electric revolution the computer
revolution giving us
enough wealth that we don't have to
constantly fight for it
and the question is can we negotiate
this
transition to type one if we can we're
talking about an age of aquarius
by the time we're type 2 by the way we
are immortal
no nothing known to science can destroy
a type 2 civilization
meteors can be deflected asteroids can
be blown up
weather can be modified no more global
warming problems
even the sun even if the sun explodes
they can leave the sun
and colonize another star system so by
the time you're type
two you are immortal the danger is the
most dangerous period
is between type zero to type one because
we still have all the savagery of the
past
yeah i asked that question because look
right now
uh 46 is one click away from
sending uh nuclear bombs all over all
over the world if you wanted to
there's that much power behind a
president right
you got a putin in russia that's got the
same kind of capabilities if somebody
upsets him
and we know if that happens there's a
domino effect right
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
wait what did you do you're going to
retaliate we have to retaliate and then
it's going to be insanity right that's
going to go back and forth
so the reason why i asked the hitler
question is because
what prevents and again this whole topic
is about there's another doppelganger
you know another
civilization around the you know space
that's like the earth
that's you said maybe a million years
ahead of us as long as there's emotion
and there's ego where someone can be
offended
don't you think there's a likelihood
that someone could pull the plug with
the level of access to explosives that
we have today
whether it's a virus whether it's bio
chemical warfare whether it's whatever
else may be
to just finish everything up and boom we
have to start all over again
well there's a note of optimism here
first of all
realize that i think that technology has
a moral direction
now that differs from what most
scientists believe most scientists
believe that technology is neutral
a sword could either cut against you or
cut with you
it's a science is a double-edged sword
but i tend to disagree
i think that technology has a moral
direction
because the internet spreads information
and it creates empowerment information
is power
powered to liberate yourself from
dictatorships and oppression
in other words it creates democracy
we have a wave of democratic movements
around the world now
when i was a kid there was an expression
called
dictator for life if you were a dictator
under the wing of russia
or the united states they couldn't get
rid of you you were
dictated for life now we laugh at that
what dictator for life you kidding
people can organize
they can educate themselves they can arm
themselves with
knowledge so the big winner is democracy
now they're going to be back they're
going to be backsliding
there's going to be problems but in the
main the internet spreads
empowerment empowerment means more
democracy
and democracies are more stable than
dictatorships
dictatorships on a whim can start a war
democracies it's very difficult to start
a war in a democracy
because you have widows you have
veterans all these people with access to
the media that may not
want a war and so i think that there are
checks and balances
so i think that the smallest unit of
history
is the decade anything smaller than a
decade you get random fluctuations
and if you look at history decade by
decade
think of where we were in the year 1900
it was a horrible year 1900 with kings
and queens and empires
the austro-hungarian empire fighting the
prussian empire
by the what all these empires fighting
each other
1900 was not a very pleasant year to
live in and of course that gave birth to
world war one
now think of what we have today sure we
have nuclear weapons
but we have empowerment taking place
with
a middle class with access to the means
to get
information instantly anywhere on the
planet earth
i think that is a good trend i mean look
you know i'm an optimist and i'm leaning
towards you but i'm also a
guy that uh subscribes to what andy
andy grove years ago the former ceo of
intel who wrote the book
only the paranoid survive i think
there's got to be an element of paranoia
to make sure we can prevent
madness from taking place and when
you're saying information and social
media and you know internet what it's
doing
how it's leaning towards democracy do
you think it is a good idea to
constantly permit for opposing ideas to
clash
and you know these these virtual
governments have a lot of power today
the twitters the facebooks the youtubes
of the world
they have a lot of power today do you
think it's
a bad idea let me say ask the question
differently do you think it's a bad idea
to prevent
from opposing ideas to clash even though
you may disagree with them
well i think that correct ideas emerge
from struggle with
incorrect ideas ideas have to clash with
each other
and if it means that some crazy ideas
are out there well so be it
you know this is the wild west the
internet is young
i mean think of technology we've had
cars since
the last century we've had trains since
the 1800s
the internet is a young technology and
as a consequence you have people who
harangue others are noisy people
people that want to beat their chest on
the internet say also crazy things
but eventually people will tune them out
eventually people will mature
because why give these people a platform
because this frees free speech
but you just can turn them off as well
because
people have to mature and i think that
when people mature
that's when the tone of the internet is
going to change from the wild west
to something that it that wants
wisdom wisdom is what we need on the
internet not haranguing but wisdom
and i think that that wisdom comes from
struggle with incorrect ideas
and it does mean that there's going to
be a wild west for a while
until people people get mature and
simply
tune out these crazy ideas because they
say well that's nonsense
but that takes a while so the internet
is still very young
i agree i mean the internet's what 20 30
40 years old depending on when you
start the internet you know you kind of
pick the time that it started so
so for you the idea of silencing a
figure like a trump is not a good idea
you got to let him be on there and say
what he's saying whether you like him or
not but to
because you know sanders and the reason
why i'm asking this question is because
again i'm going back to events
to what really irritated a guy named
adolf that he wanted to
fly i mean he was one war away siberia
he was getting close and churchill if
there's not a churchill
you and i may be speaking german today
so what do we have to do from not
offending the wrong
person where their motives comes out to
want to do something
bigger to retaliate towards a potential
civilization
so for you we ought to allow people of
opposing ideas to not be banned on
social media twitter facebook whoever
they may be
because people will eventually become
wiser and
they'll tune those ideas out well i
think you have to let
unpopular ideas uh out there
because once people have grievances they
act on these grievances
and there's a a social movement
behind many of these ideas and if you
bottle it up
it comes back in a more hideous form and
so i think that it's short-sighted
it's short-sighted to simply say we can
tune out certain ideas just because
uh we don't like these ideas i think
it's a bad idea
i i'm totally i'm totally with you i'm
i'm on the same page with you i i
i learn through debate i learn through
discourse i learn through argument
i learn through seeing people arguing
they debate going back and forth because
you're sitting there saying
never thought i would agree with him huh
that was an interesting point
really wow never had it from that point
of view and we're getting better versus
if i just only hear from one side
you're not your argument is not getting
any stronger final thoughts here before
we wrap up
i've had a fascinating time listening to
you your mind is just so interesting to
me
to want to hear what you have to say if
elon musk were to get his rocket ready
today
would you consider moving to mars with
him well
i'm a scientist and we realized that
rocket failure
takes place roughly one percent of the
time
uh take a look at the space shuttle we
had 200 or so missions of the space
shuttle
how many of them blew up two that's
exactly
one percent of the time and so people
who are astronauts
in the old days they were pilots air
force pilots
they knew that every time they got into
that capsule there was a probability
they're not going to come back
but then we begin to think of space
travel as being
a sunday picnic that i think was not a
good idea
because reality catches up with you that
one percent of the time catches up with
you
so when elon musk recently said that he
expects some people
to die on the mission to mars i think
he's preparing
the world public preparing them for the
possibility that yes
some people may die but don't have a
backlash against the space program
you know when this shuttle blew up and
seven brave astronauts
died on national television there was a
backlash
a backlash against a space program we
don't want that backlash
we want people to be honest space travel
to mars is not a sunday picnic
the mission will take two years nine
months to get there
nine months to get back and a few months
to do experiments
two years but the world's record for
being in and out of space is only one
year so we're talking about busting a
whole bunch of records
sending humans to mars i think we can do
it
i think we should do it because the
dinosaurs
did not have a space program and that's
why there are no dinosaurs in this room
right now
because they didn't have a space program
we do
but they're going to be pitfalls and i
think elon musk is right
priming the people telling them that yes
the mission to mars they're going to be
heroes
heroines but some of them will not make
it back
how long before we have civilization on
mars what do you think well
sometime after 2030 we expect to have
the first
piloted crude crude mission to the red
planet
and i don't think we should bankrupt the
earth to create a settlement on mars
but i think a settlement on mars should
be self-sustaining
so it's not a financial drain on the
planet
earth meaning that they should have
agriculture
mining robots in order to create a
self-sustaining
colony on the red planet and that is
well within
our capability when's the last time we
had a scientist as a president
i'm curious when's the last time we had
a scientist as a president america
i think the closest we came was actually
benjamin franklin
benjamin franklin actually made a
scientific history with his kite
experiments and many of his
breakthroughs
but i don't think we've ever come close
to having a scientist as president
do you think do you think the next phase
is going to be us valuing the brain of a
scientist to want to run the nation
rather than a brain of a lawyer
military entrepreneur businessman
well you know there's a danger having
lawyers and
professional politicians run the
government because the question is where
does wealth come from
to a politician wealth comes from taxes
you rob peter to pay paul
to an economist you print money but you
see that's simply robbing
other people to pay for your debts i say
wealth comes from science and technology
from the industrial revolution to the
electric revolution to the computer
revolution of today
it's science that generates the wealth
that then is divided up by politicians
who debate
and slice the pie smaller and smaller
and smaller
i say we need a bigger pie instead of
struggling with
this slice of the pie saying we want a
bigger share
your shirt has to be smaller we want to
tax this
and and put the tax money over there i
think we need a bigger pie
and where does that bigger pie come from
science and technology
so who makes it the young that's why
it's so important that we
instill this love of science in the next
generation
i love this so so basil musk could be
a president in u.s you think he would
make a good president
well gee to be a president you have to
have the temperament
of uh a horse trading uh compromise
and uh if you're a trailblazing
entrepreneur
you don't want to compromise too much
you want it now
right so i think that well there's a
benefit to having a politician who
knows how to trade horses uh because it
takes um a certain amount of uh
of back and forth to become a politician
well i gotta tell you i've really
enjoyed it i appreciate you for coming
on and being a guest on valuetainment
folks we're gonna put the link to his
book below
to go to amazon and order this book uh
uh
that that just came out on again let me
remember to date april
6th i want to say yes is it april 6 that
just came out that's already
a new york times bestseller the god
equation the quest
for a theory of everything click on the
link below to go order the book
doc once again thank you for your time
okay my pleasure great honor
probably one of my top 15 conversations
i've ever had on valuetainment i know it
sounds weird but i was just
mesmerized by the topics we discussed
right uh what it is digital immortality
i mean
digital immortality which i understand
then immortality formulas
30 less 30 percent longer lifespan
you know how level 0 to 1 and at level 2
just so many things that leaves for
arguments and debates and wanting to
learn more so i want to hear your
thoughts what was it that you took away
from the interview
and if you enjoyed this interview i also
did an interview like this with
dr steven greer who we talked about ufos
he had an experience with a ufo
that if you've never watched it before
and you like this topic i think you'll
enjoy that interview as well click over
here watch that interview
with that being said have a great day
everybody take care bye